les enjeux du 24 avril
ce sont les choix que par votre vote
vous aurez à faire dans quinze jours
et je veux vous dire ce soir que je
mettrai toutes mes forces pour
convaincre chacun que le seul projet
pour le pouvoir d'achat c'est le nôtre
que le seul projet crédible contre la
vie chère c'est le nôtre
que le seul projet des travailleurs de
tous ceux qui sont au bord du chemin
c'est le nôtre
que le seul projet de la france c'est de
l'europe c'est le nôtre
je crois en lui on nous tous quels que
soient nos parcours le milieu nous tous
quels que soient nos origines le
territoire nous tous quels que soient
nos opinions et nos croyances nous tous
c'est cela la france
alors
durant les quinze jours à venir ne
ménageons aucun effort car rien n'est
fait soyons humbles déterminé
alors convaincre chacune et chacun le 24
avril prochain nous pouvons faire le
choix d'une nouvelle époque française et
européenne le 24 avril nous pouvons
faire le choix de l'espoir le 24 avril
nous pouvons faire le choix de la france
et de l'europe ensemble
10 20 minutes
[Applaudissements]
voilà pour le discours
[Musique]